[Musique]
est-ce que vous devez vous méfier de vos
chaussures en cette époque de pandémie
est-ce que vos souliers représente un
vecteur important de transmission de
lakovic 19
c'est ce que laisse croire cette
publication qui était mise en ligne par
une personne qui se décrit comme une ex
virologue
la publication a été retirée de facebook
par son auteur mais elle continue à
circuler abondamment vous avez été
nombreux à nous écrire à ce sujet dans
ce texte on recommande de n'utiliser
qu'une seule paire de chaussures et de
la retirer aussitôt qu'on arrive à la
maison pourquoi parce qu'on dit dans le
texte que le virus le nouveau
coronavirus peut avoir une durée de vie
de neuf jours sur l'asphalté
ce qu'on sait c'est que sur certains
types de surface la durée de vie du
virus peut varier entre quelques heures
et trois jours
mais selon deux médecins avec qui j'ai
pu m'entretenir on ne peut tout
simplement pas extrapoler pas de danger
donc avec les chaussures qu'on utilise
pour marcher à l'extérieur
voici maintenant le scénario improbable
décrit par la docteur karen couach du
centre hospitalier sainte justine pour
qu'une personne doivent réellement
s'inquiéter selon elle pour que la salle
soit vraiment contaminé il faudrait que
quelqu'un éternue ou tousse très près de
la suède d'une autre personne marche
dessus arrive à la maison et à sang sur
le plancher se met à quatre pattes met
les mains au sol et ensuite ces mêmes
mais au visage
il ya même certains internautes qui ont
brandi une étude récente qui conclut que
le nouveau coronavirus peut vivre
plusieurs heures à l'air libre
encore une fois la docteure couach met
les pendules à l'heure elle précise que
ces résultats ont été obtenus dans un
laboratoire dans un contexte bien précis
avec des niveaux très élevés de virus
qui ont été obtenus grâce à un abus 10h
mais dans la vie de tous les jours en
dehors de ce genre de laboratoire
ne vous inquiétez pas si vous avez des
doutes je vous le rappelle écrivez-nous
au décrypteurs décrypteurs au pluriel à
commercial radio terrain canada.ca
sur ce soyez prudents salut
[Musique]